do I have a viable product so I got a
great question for one of my youtube
viewers love you guys USA 9283 who wrote
in to say how do i know if i have a
viable product as i'm still in the idea
phase with my invention ideas this is a
great question and one that a lot of
people go through where you have an idea
but you don't know if it's going to work
or not and you're worried about
investing money and maybe quitting your
job and taking this risk without know if
it's going to work out so i have three
suggestions for you to figure out if you
have a viable product or not the first
one is do you use it yourself okay a lot
of the best inventions in the world came
from people who had their own personal
need for it you had your own problem and
you said there's nothing out there to
solve this I'm frustrated and so you
create something and it solves our
problem for you and chances are as a lot
of people like you who have that same
problem and would be willing to pay you
for a great example is LL Bean who was
an inventor and hunter and he started
the llbean company his first product was
a hunting shoe and it came out because
when he went hunting he was so
frustrated and upset that his shoes kept
getting what you know he's sitting there
in the marsh and trying to hunt things
and his shoes kept getting wet and cold
and damp and he got sick and it's just
frustrating is that there has to be a
better way and so he created his own
hunting shoe and he knew it would work
because he used it and it was great and
it helped him solve his problem and he
knew that other people would have that
same problem I would want to buy it as
well and so his whole brand was around
outdoors and hunting and camping and all
things that he'd love to do and he
either invented products or brought on
new products into his store that he used
and he endorsed and he liked so that's
the first task do you use it do you love
it do you use your product or service
every day because it's so amazing it
saves you so much time and aggravation
step 2 is talk to people what you want
to do is start talking to people who are
potential customers people who have the
frustration that you're helping to solve
and you
going in yet and asking for an order
you're going in just to ask for help and
say hey I've got this idea I'd love to
pick your brain on it that's a lot
easier to get people to say yes to then
hey I want to come and sell you my stuff
right you're probably going to get a lot
of great reaction from that but you're
going in asking for help when you're
saying here's what I have here's what
I'm thinking about doing what do you
think how would you tweak it what are
your thoughts and they'll give you some
free advice which is great and if they
really love it they'll say hey when is
this going to be ready because I want to
buy the first one right they'll be on
board even though you're not asking for
the sale so talk to people and see you
getting that excitement from them right
is there a need for them when you talk
about your product or your idea to them
do they get animated do they want it do
they give you positive feedback and
energy and say hey I can't wait for this
thing that come out and step three is
take pre-orders so those people who
really love it you can have them pre
order your product in advance you can
create campaigns on social media you can
create campaigns on crowdsourcing web
sites like Kickstarter calm and you can
see if there's a market for this right
so you know that you love it and you use
it you know the people that you talk to
love it and would use it and now you're
ready to go and get those pre-order so
you're not spending a lot of money
before you're making money right I hate
spending money till I make you money so
you create these campaigns and see
people with pre order it right see
people are willing to pay you for those
first products there's tons of
successful campaigns they group millions
of dollars on web sites like Kickstarter
and that helps fund your startup costs
and your inventory costs and everything
you need to launch your business so
that's my three-step process to help you
understand if you have a viable product
or not one do you use it to talk to
people and three get pre-orders believe
for those who are watching you like the
video you can support me by clicking on
the link in the description leave a
comment let me know what you think and
click on my face to subscribe to the
channel thank you so much I'll see you
soon
you